alright well III 2015 hasn't officially
started yet I think maybe fall out
already nip the honor of winning III I
don't ever [ __ ] chance another day I
don't even know where to start with this
one we have a whole sheet of things to
get through let's get let's just talk
right off the top shelf number one we
have a date November 10 2015 this year
with a my I'm not many months a handful
five close enough that i never have to
reschedule holiday time to make sure
that i have not wake up and it's there
is a free fallout game out tonight if
you want to just pick that up which
looks pretty rad we'll talk about that
in a little bit and it looks so good
let's let's roll it back to the start we
had a long presentation todd howard
showed off a bunch of concept art
nonsense and then they dove into the
game first thing we saw gentleman
looking into the mirror change in his
face it was so okay so you can play as
any skin color any any you can actually
fix their face to make it look like
whatever you want to look like um but
what she surprised me about this demo is
his wife is awkwardly standing over his
shoulder and then they swapped her in
and it turns out you can play as a woman
and fallout 4 so those rumors were
correct guessing absolutely um and this
is where you make your character and I
think you can name them as well yes and
this isn't 2077 so this is the yeah
before the war happens which is
something we've only seen little parts
of in the fallout universe and after
this is a sort of a they definitely
edited down the next couple of minutes
of the early part of the game before the
the war eventually came to us shores and
but yeah one of the things they showed
here as well was that you have a baby
and the baby's based off of almost like
GTA 5 online style yeah based on the
parents or conversations look at this no
more awkwardly zooming in on faces Lucy
yeah look at this I mean well there's
all girly zoom done that guy but no it's
just yeah it's fully voiced I think
that's another big thing is that all the
main characters are fully voiced and
while the facial animations still look a
little bit awkward um it yeah like his
eyes aren't quite as lifeless as they
were in Fallout New Vegas Kevin what do
you think about that
that aspect of it open world RPG games
fully voiced for a while and sort of
fall it's always been languishing a
little back around bethesda games have
been what do you think of that addition
yeah this is really exciting I mean
everything about the presentation was
was actually really getting me excited I
mean yeah sometimes maybe it's a little
awkward the way their lips move and and
that kind of thing or where the legs
move but I don't know like I'm it seems
like they've been actually paying
attention to the RPG world around them
and said hey you know what the witcher
is doing this cool stuff dragon age is
doing this cool stuff it's about time we
should probably live up to these ideas
and we saw some of this stuff in the
trailer they revealed just the number of
weeks ago and this all have hair flying
before the vault part and an interesting
thing that happens in this one which
does exist in fallout laura is the idea
of cryogenic stasis there was vault 0
which I think was part of a new vegas is
lower which was one of the votes in
which somebody who had been around
during the 2077 was able to come out
usually or the descendants who were like
great-great-grandchildren kind of
situation where as in this the character
you create the the mother or the father
or the wife of the husband have you come
out of the vault 111 as them again the
final survivor yeah alt and here we have
our little fallout 3 esque reveal of the
landscape as well as showing off and
it's not just brown yeah another great
thing I mean I mean it's there's color
there's there's still a sense of wonder
that's not just oh god everything's been
destroyed and scorched it's kind of like
you know like obviously the world got
destroyed and now nature's kind of
claiming it back slow yes and it looks
like a lot more nature than where we saw
in the west coast in terms of like just
even bushes and whatnot or what we see
in the in the DC area in fallout 3 he
also walked super nonchalantly for
somebody who's just seen all of his
friends and family he's looking all
right felt I know is gone they try to us
aunt it down be friends are dead they
pushed the idea of the third person in
Skyrim as well a lot in there you know I
really like maybe it'll work a little
bit better than this is bad i still look
at that green fonts yeah they something
i think i'll be adjusting that because i
intend me to play but i'm sure they'll
lets you and then yeah they show off
this is
I cosworth the robot which was the
families and de facto mechanical slave
so cool thing that is that they said
that they have recorded thousands of
names yes for the child as well yeah it
done and in terms of voice acting that's
really great yeah and then this is the
they were very quick to show that you
know these conversations like in Fallout
our quest that you can walk away from
come back there you can kill him if you
want you can continue on with the quest
which was one of the sort of the main
pillars of Bethesda's games as the
ability to just murder anyone you want
the idea that you had all the choice in
the world and to do what you wanted and
just like I wanted look at those
dialogue options yeah yeah yeah hold it
yeah a nice bit of a just in terms of
the voice acting dude I just can't
believe that a game of this scale is
going to have all this I like the way
it's also saying you okay it's almost
like which your star letting you know if
this is a dialogue option with a
different color that you're going to
dive into for yeah a little bit longer
but pushing on from this we then saw
later the i guess the gas station that
we saw in the trailer and a little doggy
Alexei you must be very happy I'm really
excited that you can command the dog it
sort of reminds me of the call of duty a
couple years back Riley I were you
carefully doesn't remind you too much of
rhyme no not too much I mean there's
sort of they look similar but not too
much but I they said context kari kamiya
better to [ __ ] some shot so it's not
quite controlling the dog but it still
looks like the dog is a major component
of you navigating the landscape and you
surviving which i think is I yes yes it
reminds me of the dog from the what is
that be able to know the ubisoft game
without the wall valiant hard way to go
pick things up and get them for you hmm
which looks like you can do a lot
earlier on the demo when they showed off
the the dog for the first time picking
up that wrench and that sort of area
that you had which we were speculating
was where you'd be building weapon parts
and building and your suit and whatnot
and then they showed off as well the
VATS is back we got your bets yes I
think a lot of people probably happy
about that and they showed off a lot of
Boston as well and this one they didn't
really allude to the scale of the world
but it's only
looked a lot more varied in terms of
color pilot disclaimer yeah I think
starting with all the concept I was very
smart thing to do as well because if
they could have just dropped you in and
you would've been like um well you know
this is it but with a concept i'll show
the real scale of the different kinds of
environments that's claws are back i
look so good to look at the way they
move like like a thing as a list of what
that fallout 3 block of mellow meet ya
we saw radroaches we saw rad scorpions
we saw mole rats on one of the concept
are things there was a there's a
protector Tron there I we saw mole rat
Queen looking at it's like a zombie ass
person feral guru that's 100 Jesus yeah
nope the variety game I guess they were
hammering home the idea of gameplay
variety which has always been a massive
pillar for the Fallout games but look at
this this [ __ ] just calling their
support and then you're in is like oh
I'm just gonna get up there at all yes
my gosh the first game that had for
flying this in their engine was the
killer teddy bear and the one of the
expansion packs for Skyrim it you fly
around so I guess they pulled that stuff
in check yes very much i'm actually i
don't think i've ever seen seen a press
conf it or they've shown this much
footage i think this is like going in
the in the record books or hall of fame
or v3 for most groundbreaking most
impactful economy mr. Sherman Duvall
look at this take that Megaton guys
don't know what like good on Bethesda
for waiting until the game was almost
done to hell yeah but are you good on
them but even then they weren't finished
they showed off that big gameplay
montage after waxing lyrical about the
game forever and then they pull you back
in and show you all this stuff like they
basic [ __ ] with the monster this is
hearthfire basically but yeah really
expanded its a you know think about
what's happened in the world since the
last fall I can come at games like rust
and and looking at like online survivor
games and not only can you build your
own house being your own community yeah
and defenses I mean it looks like
there's gonna be some kind of like
defense minigame here where you're like
you're gonna you're already attacked you
see the M there was a great tower
defense mod for skyrim there's someone
made and learn i would love if this was
a kind of run off of that hmm so in this
you can build your own house you can
the store make place to store your
pip-boy store your weapons you can make
terminals and then presumably probably
program them like the idea that you
could do all this for a house and then
also set up electrical things and you
had they said you had to collect water
and food for the people who your father
and all this is actually optional it's
like not necessarily part of the core of
all I fork experience and now you can
carry 40,000 pounds in your inventory if
they talked about in conference yet not
yet but I have to assume please help
raise it a little bit this is a plot
across to carry around and does all
these all these jerks artillery old
traps and if that wasn't enough then
they show off that you know powerful
going around collecting loose and then
building your own world you can also do
the same thing for our weapons and I
have any weapons but weapon components
yeah not even weapon components for
power armor her it's a look like this
nonsense it got really miss grizzy here
and they're like oh you don't have to do
any of this stuff he's like oh by the
way this is just there if you can't want
it it's all good look this is all stuff
we did we made this iphone a game on the
side oh yeah by the way like you can
play video games on the pip-boy hot and
listen to tapes on that's like a donkey
kong kind of game right there yeah and
then just when you thought there wasn't
enough of this madness they announced
that an actual physical pip-boy is also
big mate what a touch just stick your
phone in that yeah suddenly it's like oh
it's got a touch screen it's actually
more advanced than the real pit boys uh
who's picking with one of these up
absolutely i'll totally get why everyone
can't even with that pit boy I don't
even know where what I would do with it
where would I wear it what would I ever
all day every day can you imagine you
just think about all the people to walk
her in San Francisco what Apple watches
on you can be really all be walking
around boys all day long some next-level
nerdom yeah it's like he did listen to I
don't want to see the world on fire over
and over and over three dog you might be
able to get three doggone it all the
time can you oh just get his own radio
station yeah tvvv been laying low oh my
god ah yeah and then at the end they
dropped the bombshell am I guess 11 11
11 was all dated for Skyrim sure so 11
taunton
11 yeah the tenth of November 2015 will
be able to play fallout 4 like you for
that I actually cannot think of an e3
game announcement that had this much
impact I know it's like at the moment
afterwards really caught up in the
fervor yeah but Kevin can you think of
anything that's been quite as overtaking
is this no well seven or loss for work
it's finally happened oh my qualifying
observe it today's is better than the
Killzone 2 trailer oh yeah because we
can believe this this is actually
gameplay we looking at the only moon dog
that's hot like any kind of a similar
reaction was the the xbox one ps4 price
thing yes no I just just a moment of
everyone going no and that's basically
what happened in this war room when they
announced the release date I think this
was this butter this is bad yeah a
hundred percent how many days until
November 10 2015 148 days four hours 24
minutes and 36 seconds that's how long
we have to wait to play fallout 4 uh
yeah I don't think there's anything I
cryostasis now yes so that like tomorrow
it'll just be here let's all go into
cryostasis but I stay tuned to gamespot
com for continuing coverage of Fallout 4
for the next 148 days we've also got a
bunch of other games to talk about here
and another one they showed up they
started the show off with actually was
doom and I was left a bit cold with this
one what did you think Lucy um I was
excited because they said it was it tech
6 mmm Oh 666 as they call it and I was
always spend the whole thing I looking
at and then I was like it lists it looks
pretty don't look that pretty if it was
ok what did you think about the the
locomotion in a kevin was it supposed to
be fast sue doom has always been it felt
feels way more fast than that to me yeah
like I don't know like it just fault
thing I think I think 40 demo though hmm
I mean obviously when you play Doom it
is incredibly fast paced and whatever
but I think for a demo you can't put
that on screen because if you're showing
off your engine as well especially for
the first time properly you want to be
able to see say to people look at all
this crap we built like look at it look
at
it looks whatever you don't appreciate
this when you play it you look at now
every time he lifted up a gun I was like
oh look at the guns you're getting hard
looking at the gun now it's like
Sophie's applied on a dead body and the
guy was you know like there was forced
by I like that so this was the demo they
showed afterwards but the original part
of this that they showed off was on a
straight up like old Mars base like this
is definitely base within the same world
that they're going for with with with
dhoom 3 in terms of the UAC holding a
base and then and the hell hellscape
opening up we get some footage of
that'll to be great and that whole
section that they showed off introduced
a bunch of the weapons are on offer they
showed the shot go on the super shotgun
and they also showed off a lot of these
contextual deaths that they say yeah
yeah a lot of environmental stuff as
well like really big explosions by
shooting things in the environment which
is cool I was it just me ur that you
guys think that they were people
repeating a lot of those death sequences
over and over again I saw quite a few of
the one where they rip off the leg and
him in the head with it I thought there
was a lot of a repetitiveness I think in
the gameplay the one where it was just
like the leg left standing in the half
body yeah yeah it's like running yeah it
was just a bit it'sit's weird because he
was plowing through so many of these
characters like it was it was almost
felt like something like Bulletstorm
were you're just soaking these dudes up
and for me like I know that when you go
back and think about do one and two now
they're not the scariest games in the
world but those games had an element of
like this is hard like it's me up
against hordes and hordes of enemies and
if you're setting it right you're you're
in a difficulty that actually feels like
it's it's it's challenging obviously
they can't you know show that off at a
conference and have you dying over and
over again but there's something about
this it just seemed like it felt like
more like serious sam as soon as Sam was
on the ridiculous end of that how much
yeah I get that I get that a lot I'm
just bored by a lot of this honestly and
I feel bad because I know that some of
my Twitter feed was like oh it's
exciting and look at all the gore and
then some more of the look at the gore
and also did you notice the blood and
yeah and I'm just like this is this is
first person shooter the first person
like this is the first person shooter
the first person shooter the first
person she like it's just is what it is
and I just kind of
affected more I guess it doesn't mean
that I don't think a game can just be
it's okay for a game to just be fun but
I'm just looking at it thinking but what
is it that this is bringing me that I
can already get in pain killer and a
bunch of other games it's yeah you'll
very much like this it felt to me like
the type of game has been passed through
a bunch of different like public like
testing and just round it off because
not only like they're returning all
these games dr. bf3 one that is whatever
is back there like they're showing off
the plasma gun they're showing off all
of these guns and they all looks like
the same great thing it was basically
shooting projectiles there was no like
feeling of oh this is like different
like there was in so many right games
like quake 2 is like the best grenades
in video game ever like the railgun you
think like to me or this felt more like
a quick I even said quite there this
felt more like a quake in terms of your
ability to just mow down tons and tons
of enemies yeah me just didn't feel like
a doom at all and i was thinking of
unreal when during moments like this
where he's just switching between the
different the different types of weapons
and thinking oh that doesn't like a
little bit like unreal tournament so
regardless of our impressions of the
gameplay they showed off some other
stuff at snap map which is their new
technology for yes for sending dick pics
around the world and doom no percent for
making a levels which in and of itself
is a little bit worrying if they're
making modular level design for a game
that you know in fact yeah I think
that's cool in that they're trying to
introduce that to a new audience like
console especially yeah that's cool if
the tool kit works and if it's intuitive
enough that people obviously jump on it
um it's an up next they showed off some
multiplayer things as well they had a 4
on 4 and 4 m mode in there they had or
wave base mode in there as about the
time I was starting to fall asleep he
mentioned cooperative mode cause of the
way very first one and they said 2016 as
well and yeah part of so it's coming out
next year maybe we'll see more office
maybe being a little bit rough on and I
don't know it's just i came out at ibis
probably do fine thinking that wasn't
too hard also this is part of Bethesda
net which is their new yeah WB play
anymore bows exactly their new origin
any problem which is an online
environment in which all of these games
will be launched a bull and whatnot I
don't know I was glad they finished
before I
because for me the doom enhancement
wasn't wasn't too hot final thoughts on
doom Alexa I don't think I've seen
enough to really be like whoo yet I mean
it looks fun but beyond that I yeah it's
their name all right I guess we'll have
to wait and see ya that's not what you
think of doom in the comments are we
being a little bit too tough on it were
you disappointed as well or did you
think it looks pretty badass let us know
down below all right we got a bunch more
games to get through next up dishonored
dose oh my God look are there any cold
winds back as well uh who's the biggest
dishonored find here let's go all right
go go for what you think um I'm I'm
really excited I'm really glad that it's
not it's technically that it it picks up
from the last game like I really like
the world I was hoping for a prequel but
I the idea that you get to play as Emily
who I'm not going to spoil it because
they announced dishonored definitive
edition they did so if you haven't yet
it's coming to playstation 4 and xbox
one so i won't spoil it but emily is a
very important character from the first
game that doesn't get a lot of not a lot
of the spotlight yeah and I'm also very
very excited that they showcased her in
the trailer you can play as Emily or as
Corvo but they focused on her and it
reminded me i hate to call this out but
it reminded me of the syndicate reveal
Assassin's Creed syndicate where you
have the male and female playable
protagonist but they led with Jacob
which is the boy I really liked what I
saw so you can pay his book her on Corbo
in it either or I think you get to pick
um it looks great it looks like the
world has sort of tect up a little bit
it looks a little bit more evolved from
the last game I'm really excited to see
where this goes story-wise cuz the
narrative was one of my favorite things
about dishonored speaking of that does
this look like the same city same
environment that was in the first game
no this looks entirely different looks
yeah her out of you see it's a CG
trailer so we can't really take yes you
are man but it looks somatically similar
but a very very different aesthetic and
we were talking before the show and live
about how the dishonored came out and
had a great sort of an art style to it
but maybe technically didn't wow us and
the ways that we would have hoped
especially we're probably because at the
end of that generation those consoles
were looking a little bit light in terms
of technical pro eyes and but in terms
of gameplay and why not here was there
anything else that stood out to you guys
in terms of like the weapons the power
is
Emily was wielding she's the smoke
monster from lost apparently yeah she's
got Jackie Estacado his darkness beings
or something happening oh it was cool I
mean obviously we saw a look at I think
she had the blink she had the time
slowed down she was all some kind of
like grappling hook hmm I'm just used to
scale across buildings there and
obviously the crossbow which Corvo used
a great fight oh there it is come out of
head yeah it looks like when it comes
from like prototype yeah um but yeah it
looks cool and I mean I'm yeah I'm just
excited to see more really we don't have
a date on this one as of yet but it said
that no they didn't say spring no they
said did you say that I look at the
wrong note PC Xbox Playstation and the
dishonored definitive edition which
interestingly enough who called us at
and that there was somebody who said it
to us beforehand yes Phil wait 75 before
the show said do you think they'll be a
decided to remaster and yeah called it
so we're gonna have an HD version of
this honored coming head to playstation
4 xbox one did they say pc for that one
as well alright so you can pay your HD
finally play dishonored in HD as this
year yeah and that's that's pretty much
all that happened here at the Bethesda
coffers somewhat a little bits and bobs
and but I a dishonored was probably
another one of the biggest games so yeah
for continuing coverage of dishonored
and all the other games Bethesda show
off here and all the games we're gonna
have a t3 make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot com alright that's it they want
dawn already crazy amazing we go nuts
I'm gonna go watch the replay of that
for that thing a couple more times at
kevin van [ __ ] Lucy James like sorry
Korea thank you so much for join me
today they doing a gay spot we'll be
back what time tomorrow morning early
8am Microsoft my god that's right yeah
yeah so maybe nine maybe 9 Pacific
changer for your own local time but of
course on gamespot com for Sashi 3 we
have all the times of all the press
conferences big day tomorrow live at
eight thirty in the morning so make sure
you wake up early and check us at that
but until then if you're in Europe go to
go to bed well done to staying up if
you're in the States
yeah get some early rest because we got
a big day video games coming up tomorrow
thanks everyone production team I will
see you guys tomorrow take care